[Music]
and welcome to Hannity history on
Capitol Hill tonight eight Republican
lawmakers joining all 208 house
Democrats to remove Kevin McCarthy as
house Speaker the first time in our
nation's history and McCarthy will not
seek the speakership again now sources
telling me at this hour some House
Republicans have been in contact with
and have started an effort to draft
former president Donald Trump to be the
next speaker and I have been told
that President Trump might be open to
helping the Republican party at least in
the short term if necessary if it's
needed anyway but here's former speaker
McCarthy earlier tonight let's take a
look
I believe I can continue to fight maybe
in a different manner
I will not run for speaker again
I'll have the conference pick somebody
else
I think today was a political decision
by the Democrats and I think I think the
things they have done in the past hurt
the institution
when they just started removing people
from committee they just started doing
the other things and I my fear is the
institution fell today
because you can't do the job
if eight people you have 94 of or 96
percent of your entire conference but
eight people can partner with the whole
other side
how do you govern and for them to make a
motion on me because I made a decision
for the country
that they agreed with
they choose to do the other that becomes
a problem
now this all went down after a motion to
vacate was put forward by Florida
Congressman Matt Gates citing trust
issues because of a recent bipartisan
resolution a CR to fund the government
through mid-november and a lack of
action on a number of bills
Appropriations bills and Gates went
forward with a move to house Speaker
McCarthy successful anyway given the
slim GOP majority Gates needed only a
handful of other Republicans to get it
done but now uncertainty Reigns Supreme
on Capitol Hill in truth Gates other
Republicans they did have legitimate
complaints returning to regular order
passing Appropriations bills single
issue bills balanced budget amendment
term limits all promised Fair criticism
but many of those measures could have
been dealt with especially in the future
especially issues that would never have
been come law at this time really came
down to the fiscal issues in at in play
here the Appropriations process for
example but the question is this and
every conservative every Republican
needs to be asking this tonight was this
the best strategic and tactical Approach
at this moment now there were very very
viable Alternatives plans put together
by Freedom caucus members people like
Congressman chip Roy who will join us
tonight and Byron Donalds and Scott
Perry for example one plan cut from them
cut spending by a whopping eight percent
and also had historic border security
measures attached but was opposed by
Gates and a few other Republicans and
that didn't go far that left chip Roy
kind of speechless that plan would have
allowed more time needed for the
Appropriations bills to be passed and
the sex second option actually added 30
percent cut in discretionary spending
and included by the way the Republican
party's border bill h.r-2 that would
have been a great alternative that again
would have also resulted in the full 12
Appropriations bills having been voted
on and hopefully passed so today the
question we all have was the nuclear
option needed was it worth it well I can
tell you right now I don't know time
will certainly tell whether this is a
good move or a bad move but one reality
will not change Republicans have a
minuscule majority whoever the speaker
is and it is made up of disparate groups
ranging moderate left to Freedom caucus
conservative now Gates says that he was
ripping the Band-Aid off the status quo
in the Washington swamp but the house
oversight committee chairman Jim Jordan
had a different take let's hear him
on January 3rd we said the 118th
Congress is about three things past the
bills that need passed do the oversight
work that needs to be done and stop the
inevitable Omnibus that comes from the
United States Senate right before the
holidays
Kevin McCarthy has been Rock Solid on
all three
we have passed the bills we told the
American people we would pass 87 000 Ira
s agents bat built that bill passed
parents Bill of Rights that bill passed
energy legislation passed border
security immigration enforcement
legislation the strongest bill ever to
pass the Congress passed earlier this
year
we have done what we told them we were
going to do
all right now keep in mind Republicans
hold a nine vote majority in one half of
one-third of the federal government uh
making up that very slim majority as a
coalition of lawmakers he got the
freedom caucus the Tuesday Thursday
Friday Sunday group the study group
along with moderate Republicans many
from districts that Biden won in 2020 18
to be exact now bringing that group
together on anything is not an easy feat
but in the end Republicans let me warn
you tonight you will succeed or you will
fail together that is undeniable still
McCarthy accomplished a lot including a
serious investigation into Biden's
bribery money laundering allegations
which is ongoing an impeachment inquiry
that is now picking up steam an
investigation into Biden's weaponized
FBI and doj multiple major pieces of
legislation including a border security
bill that I just mentioned a bill to
stop Biden's plan to hire 80 000 new IRS
agents a bill to stop big government
restrictions on gas stoves and other
appliances another bill to repeal the
worst parts of the so-called inflation
reduction act and that's just the tip of
the iceberg but now without a speaker
all matters involving the house come to
a grinding halt the gop's investigations
will be stalled zero Republican bills
will be sent to the Senate and
Republican infighting that'll take
Center Stage which is exactly what
Democrats and the media mob desperately
want and they want to continue for a
long period of time now president Trump
earlier today even in the midst of
what's going on in New York took time to
post this on true social why is it that
Republicans are always fighting among
themselves why aren't they fighting the
radical left Democrats who are
destroying our country oh I happen to
agree with the president we are now a
year away from the single most pivotal
election of our lifetime it's all on the
line now Democrats are destroying the
rule of law Equal justice equal
application of our laws is dead and by
the way as we've seen Donald Trump and
his family are now being targeted in
ways this country has never seen before
Joe Biden and his family are shielded
protected around every turn by Joe's
weaponized doj the border is an absolute
disaster nightmare National Security
risk our economy is a disaster Americans
are suffering more than at any point in
my lifetime inflation is through the
roof gas prices are through the roof and
going higher by the way and our
commander-in-chief has real significant
cognitive issues that everybody in the
world can see because it's that
transparent he is neither physically nor
mentally fit to serve this country House
Republicans can't can solve their
differences behind closed doors how
about you get in a room you throw away
your phone and uh maybe you stay in that
room order pizza and don't come out
until you agree knowing how important
these Appropriations his bills were I
have a criticism why did the Republicans
take off the month of August in the end
this may all turn out fine I'm not
hitting the panic button tonight however
the American people's patience it will
run out quickly here and so the GOP take
my advice if you want it seems a lot of
people never take it be careful and you
better get a new speaker quickly
Democrats they want you in complete
disarray they want a distraction away
from their failed policies and their
feeble president and they'd really love
a few moderate Republicans to peel off
and actually vote for a Democrat for
speaker so will the GOP rally behind the
new speaker will anyone even want the
job or will this end in a disaster I
cannot answer that question tonight but
time will tell we expect a vote on a new
speaker sometime next week chairman Jim
Jordan will join us in a moment first
here with reaction we have former
Speaker of the House Fox News
contributor Newt gingriches with a are
welcome let's get your overall thoughts
on this today
well first I think it's a very sad day
because I think Kevin McCarthy is one of
the most talented leaders I've ever
worked with I think that he accomplished
an amazing amount for having a small
majority and being having to take on
both the Senate and the White House and
I think this is really a tragic outcome
this was a leader who both gained seats
in 2020 gained seats in 2022 increased
the number of women members increase the
number of veterans increase the number
of minority members and had a vision for
a better future
and let's be clear here Sean uh you know
if if the University of Georgia Bulldogs
were the number one team in the country
right now if you started a game and four
of the members of the offensive Squad
decided they were actually on the
Alabama side and began tackling your own
people
you probably get them off the field
well think about what we saw today
four percent
four percent decided they were so
morally Superior so intellectually pure
so patriotically better
that they would side with the Democrats
and that's what they did
in order to defeat the entire Republican
house caucus 96 percent of the
Republicans voted for McCarthy four
percent voted against him from my
position as a longtime Republican
activist they're traitors all eight of
them should in fact be primaried they
should all be driven out of public life
what they did was to go to the other
team to cause total chaos we ought to be
focusing on Biden we ought to be
focusing on the economy we ought to be
focusing on the border instead you're
going to get a week or 10 days of the
media focusing on Republican disarray
it's an astonishingly destructive
Behavior by a handful of egocentric
people who think they're Superior to 96
percent of the conference look I I do
think on the on on Kevin's side let me
let me analyze this more than anything
else it is hard to appreciate the very
tiny majority that Kevin McCarthy was
working with you have moderate to
Liberal Republicans a 18 of them you
know in districts that voted for Joe
Biden they want to keep their jobs so
they're not going to be as conservative
on a lot of these issues so it's hard to
bring a small caucus like that together
it's like herding cats I wouldn't want
the job you couldn't pay me to do that
job there's no amount of money I'd take
for that job on the other hand I do have
a little frustration with with Kevin too
why didn't he as promised go forward
with the Appropriations bills regular
order which by the way you brought back
when you were a speaker that led to the
the first and last balanced budgets we
had in you know decades on both ends so
um you found a way to get that done why
did they go away for August when they
should have been he knew this fight was
coming why did they go away
look let me answer the two very
different levels first of all the house
through regular order has passed 70
percent of the government in
Appropriations the Senate has passed
zero so Kevin actually was on a track
and in the next few weeks that assuming
they can get around to it they will
actually finish all of the
Appropriations I think that was just
baloney second all of these 18
Republicans in the Biden districts
they actually voted for the two
conservative continuing resolutions you
described earlier they voted for him
even though they were very conservative
who killed them
the hard right why did the hard right
kill them because they were against any
continuing resolution well if you didn't
want the government closed if you didn't
want the military not to be paid if you
didn't want the border patrol not to be
paid and the hard right says to you I
ain't doing nothing what are you going
to do and Kevin did what you had to do
what I would have done frankly in his
case but it wasn't the 18 Biden
districts that was a problem that's true
it was Hardcore hard right people and
those hard right people could go back
home and explain why did they think this
was better no but they need to be held
their feet to the fire why did they
think it was better to be too solid
conservative continuing resolutions that
as you pointed out includes the Border
includes deep spending cuts did
everything they claimed there for
you know why they did it because
ultimately Matt Gates who hates let's be
clear he hates Kevin McCarthy was not
about it to find a way to get to today
is disgraceful and I hope they expel him
from the conference I would have gone
along yet Byron Donald's Freedom caucus
member Scott Perry Freedom caucus member
chip Roy will be on the show tonight
Freedom caucus member you know they had
two separate plans they put together and
you are a hundred percent right they
were voted down by the conservatives
that would have been the perfect bridge
to get to number one have Cuts have
border security cuts in spending and get
us to the Holy Grail which was the
Appropriations bills that would have
been completed that to me was the answer
and no they went against it I don't know
why because but consent consider well
you do know why consider
the moderates you described all voted
voted tough very conservative
service it was the hard right that voted
against them and people back home ought
to take a look at how their member voted
and asked are you just terminally stupid
do you do you prefer to have everything
screwed up and in terms of the eight
people who voted today with the
Democrats and let's be clear they're not
Republicans they shouldn't frankly they
should I wouldn't if I were a speaker
they wouldn't be in the conference I'd
say to them you prove to me
the conference ought to be for
Republicans well then Hakeem Jeffries
this speaker that doesn't work either
why everything Bliss I came will take
the speakership if you give up the
investigation of Biden if you give up
the effort to get spending if you give
up the effort to stop regulations if you
give up the fight against woke policy I
mean he's available and maybe these
eight guys would be more comfortable
being with Hakeem Jeffries and that
totally insane policy rather than
pretending that they're Republicans they
better get this fixed fast the patience
of the American people will run run out
very quickly uh speaker Gingrich thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else